the question is how does the how do
those habits line up with the Rodriguez
who doesn't care to take you yeah man
who doesn't care to wrestle you and only
wants what volcanovski chooses
which is free-flowing outside movement
switching stance
not only are you do you have the the
duties of being one of the top analysts
but you know you're still competing at
the highest level dude so you're
juggling both things
one of the things I love about talking
to you Brendan is you're one of the few
people have done that job and then left
it and then still know what it feels
like you know and um
yeah I think that you also know you also
competed in the UFC so you know Both
Worlds and a lot of people there's a
couple that have done it but not a lot
you know like a handful of us yeah we
all work together yeah but the outside
like World Fighters
um uh even fans
I mean I've been doing TV for 10 years
while I've been competing against the
best guys in the world and nobody
nobody knows that I'm doing two two
three four jobs while everybody else is
just fighting correct like uh nobody
knows that it's just like it's expected
or something or like it's easy to do the
TV job and it's really not it's because
they don't they don't know anything else
I think they would notice if you were
bad at it or if you messed up then it
would be privy to it like man why you
know why is this happening then then
someone have to explain was also
training full-time competing at a world
championship level like oh that makes
sense but because you're operating at
such a high level it's almost like
they're they're not privy to it you know
what I'm saying like if something was
slack and then those glittering holes
would come out so it's kudos to you but
then also our boy our mutual friend John
annik you know I talked to John all the
time
and he was saying that you know everyone
prepares but he's like nobody prepares
like Dominic Cruz he's like as far as he
would say that because he does prepare
like me we're the we're two of the ones
doing that at the same time
so thank you for for mentioning Annie
too because you're right uh Brandon he
works have you seen him get ready
prepare you've done some TV yes nuts
absolutely nuts but you he says
writing notes you know yeah you but but
he said you're V you're the same like
the way you are very meticulous with
your fighting career and everything that
goes into that you're doing the same on
the TV side he's like it's nuts because
he goes you don't see that a lot usually
those guys that show naturally gifted
where they can kind of slack off and
especially if they're still competing
he's like Dom is not that way and that's
Kudos dude that's why you're gonna be
successful no matter this TV stuff goes
away fighting goes away you take that
work ethic and you put it in any field I
mean we're going Sizzler daddy thanks
Brandon and that's what you've done
that's why I'm here on the show with you
because you created this from scratch
yeah kept going kept going kept going
even while everybody hates or whatever
just keep making your way one foot in
front of the other and I think the
reason I'm bringing this up is because
you mentioned TV
I get a lot of and then I said I
mentioned that a lot of athletes don't
know what it is that well I get I'll get
questions from guys like at the PDI like
hey uh how do I get a how did you get on
TV like how do I get us a slot like that
and I think it's like almost seen like
if I just got there or something or if I
just like and it's like I I can remember
driving three hours Zach candido had me
do this I don't know if he had anybody
else to do it but it helped me prepare
so I'm grateful in the end but I had to
drive three hours to La every weekend to
do shootout fights uh to do color
commentary for shootout fights and I
remember getting to those cards and
you're in a little tiny room because the
fights happen to somewhere else so
you're in a room with a white
a whiteboard behind you and you're just
looking at this little TV for seven
hours uh commentating but the second you
get there the entire Fight Card changes
boom you don't know one person on the
whole card and everybody speaks
everything's in Portuguese so I think
it's when when people ask me like if the
pi like Hey how do I get a TV spot I
immediately go all the way to that to
that time yeah and I'm like well I mean
you could get a try out and then see
what happens I'm not gonna say you're
not gonna be able to do it anybody can
come do this do a tryout but I think the
hard part is the work after that tryout
is more than you might think like oh a
lot of work yeah you're not just showing
up on Saturday night and like hey how's
it going guys you know people don't
people don't realize you're not just
hanging out with the boys like you're
doing a freaking fight campaign with me
like there's a lot of work that goes
into it then I think a lot of Fighters
there's there's some that can do it to
the level of like you in a DC that's far
and few between and I think they should
just do the audition or just take the
tryout you know and see how it goes just
a lot tougher than you think it it
really is and then I'll get off your
nuts after this but I remember when I
was like I always knew you were a beast
but I remember you and I were working on
the fox lot together
and I think it was like UFC tonight or
whatever it was back then for Fox and I
remember the UFC I forget what sponsor
it was it might have been Reebok or
something like that but I remember they
wanted to put it on the set with us and
they were in the big execs were in the
room and you were not having it and at
the time I was like well actually I
don't remember that oh dude it was so
gangster yeah it was I think it might
have been you me and bizbing or you me
and Karen Bryant I forget and I just
remember you like nah man nah I'm not no
it's not happening like because they
they weren't paying the fighters yet and
you're like until there's a deal in
place I don't want to associate and I
was like yeah yeah me too I just
remember you were you were like so
adamant about it and I was like damn
like we're gonna get kicked out of here
but that just changed my way of thinking
I'm like no he's right dude he's right
like they're eating all the pie and then
they want us to rep this stuff but we're
not benefiting from it and I just
remember going home I remember my
girlfriend I'm my wife now I might go at
home being like you should have seen
Dominic Cruz man like he was not having
it she's like really I'm like yeah I
think they're gonna fire me but he's
good you know and that's what happened
we've had some weird run-ins and I don't
think it's really like get on each other
not just as much as dude we're talking
about past experiences that we've had
with one another it's like it is what it
is yeah it's a respect I think yeah yeah
I mean it can be you can call it
whatever you want but I don't feel it
that way oh no I'm just being silly man
but yeah I just I'll never forget that
like I don't think people realize like
on those Fox Lots like when you're in
there and all the executives
and there's like there's a tired team
behind it and usually just you know you
do your thing but doc was out of half
and I was like man that is Gangster dude
I actually loved working at Fox with all
those guys you know I I did they were
really cool crew totally different from
ESPN too it's been cool to be with the
UFC through that TV uh thing too because
I watched the sport grow with the TV so
I started when I started fighting it was
on Spike on the ultimate fighter that
was it and then I fought Demetrius
Johnson on versus yeah so like nobody
even saw that fight that leads me to
this so you look and you've been with
the company so long especially working
not only as a fighter but an analyst too
you you know you go through the verse
the spike days the verses the Fox Sports
and other ESPN the sports gotten so big
now you have two billionaires in Elon
Musk and Mark Zuckerberg and Dana White
kind of be in the middleman there being
the Don King of it all what you I want
your take on how you feel if it were to
come to fruition I don't think the fight
actually happens but if it did
the how do you feel about it happening
in the UFC Dom so this goes back to the
DNA of us as humans like we all have
fighting us so like
now with the internet it changes the
fight game right because the fight game
can be seen anywhere before it had to be
a live event so the athletes had to be
worth the live event and worth bringing
everybody together but on the internet
nobody has to leave their house nobody
has to do anything so having a live
event just needs to be entertaining
people not an entertaining fight and
that's what's interesting about this is
Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg are two
people who are people are more
fascinated with these human beings than
most people in the world not because of
fighting but just because of what they
create yeah and then how they've seemed
to be on a side versus a side or
people have attached to them to put them
in a box to create them on a side
correct there's all this stuff so once
you create two sides you have a
competition it's win and lose once you
create a competition with people that
everybody is interested in and then you
add the internet to it it no longer
needs to be two fighters it just needs
to be two entertaining people they can
bring everybody together and I think
that
to look past these guys
because they're not Fighters is crazy
because of the internet now if it wasn't
for the internet I would say what are we
wasting our time here let's use these
live events for the highest level of
athlete but these guys like they could
add to it you could throw them in there
you could do something like that and
we're talking about the highest some of
the highest political people in the
world right now whether they want to be
or not they are in part by the human
race they're just political entities in
the world right
and then you think
what if you could get Donald Trump and
Biden to fight like even if even if that
wasn't a pro fight and they're like 100
years old everybody on Earth would tune
into that so now we're starting to look
at the big the big picture is just it's
always been about who will tune in why
do you think slap fighting is doing so
well it's a viral Moment by viral moment
caught on the internet because viral
moments are all that matter that's why
off this
off this entire conversation all you're
going to do is take a 30-second blip yep
you're gonna take a five second lip and
that's all sat fighting has done they've
taken a full fight correct by companion
they've taken a full podcast and they've
chopped up the good bits and they put it
out there for people to get hits on is
it a good thing though Dom like
business-wise it makes sense this is
where I'm at on it
it part when it first got announced like
this is insane man like what are we
doing here like this is the road we're
headed down I understand it and uh and
part of me like what the hell are we
doing this is crazy you know how hard
after work to fight in the UFC man just
because these guys are billionaires now
they just jump to the head of the queue
part of that was in me now
as I sit on it I'm just like oh I would
watch it I get why people want it I get
why Dana White wants to be involved in
he's a businessman it's gonna be the
biggest fight of all time the product
we're gonna get is gonna be good no as
far as we're concerned as far as all the
fights we've watched it's gonna be very
low level fighting which could be
entertaining itself
but and I and so I I get it's going to
be it's gonna be the most watched fight
of all time even though it's not a high
level fighting so so I I have a I have a
love-hate relationship with it
completely get it and I I obviously I'd
be into it if it does happen
but a part of me is like does
you know they were talking about it
would be on a on a UFC card maybe the
main event and it's like and they're
like yeah bring eyeballs to the other
guys that doesn't work for me that
doesn't really work like that that
narrative's never worked name the guy
who fought before CM Punk you know or
name the fight before James Tony Randy
Couture did it help though yeah but CM
Punk got um some of the most record
pay-per-view Buys in the history of
Pay-Per-View fights correct and it
helped the UFC it helped the UFC it
helped it helped Dana White but to help
the the rest of the roster probably not
you know but I don't have an issue with
that I'm saying that argument really
doesn't work for me to go well if Elon
Musk is fighting and we put say Patty
pimlin Underneath Him Patty's can get
way bigger game more fans I think that
audience that's going to tune in is
going to tune in for that one like weird
fight and then they're not gonna stick
around for the sport the majority aren't
there's not a chance but I'm not even
mad at that argument I just I just I
don't know like if I look at the NFL
then they would never entertain this
stuff now fighting is different you
couldn't put you couldn't put them and
that's a game
so to be honest with that if you're
gonna compare it to basketball football
you couldn't because that's a game and
fighting is not a game fighting is like
just what we are like fighting you
anybody can do fighting not anybody
can shoot a basketball and play football
they can anybody can throw football now
the game they do it well can they do it
like Tom Brady absolutely not now can
Elon Musk throw a kick like Dominic Cruz
absolutely not but we're going back to
the DNA which is fighting is in our DNA
since the beginning of time basketball
and football is not so yeah it's
different there because that's a game
that's been made up later in history
fighting has been around since we were
on this Earth for sure it's in our DNA
so everybody can tune and understand
yeah fight and why we do it everybody
and even these two guys
I hear what you're saying but I do
somewhat I do believe it will bring eyes
like I just do I mean there are so many
yeah you're right there's a lot that
might say oh I watched that once I will
never go back but let's say the buys go
up to the
you know a record amount how many what's
the percentage of those record amount
that do stay because they have these
types of fights yeah even if it's one
percent off let's say it does 15 million
one percent it's a massive number yeah
that's all I'm looking at and
realistically we I look at it again like
Joe Rogan like all right maybe Joe Rogan
doesn't have the fight
um experience as an actual fighter maybe
he doesn't um have certain fight you
know attributes as as me and DC because
we fought and we've been championed yes
but we need Joe Rogan there we just need
him there he is one of the most listened
to voices in the world and you know even
though I don't always agree with what he
says in the booth because we see the
sport from different we see the martial
arts from a different angle it doesn't
mean that I don't believe I absolutely
love to have him oh Hunter's voice
mindset his questions and even the fact
that he doesn't know quite as much
sometimes supports I believe the
audience I agree and I believe that
watching Elon Biden fight and watching I
don't think the physical but yeah
I'm with the same guy anyway
um
with those two guys fighting I'm just
like man
like this is this could really like just
bring some weird things to the table you
know yeah I just I want like the can of
worms is gonna open it's like you know
what's next what's already open the
internet opened the can of worms not the
not the UFC
I agree yeah yeah that's a fair point
yeah you got some good uh points here
and I to argue on your side too again
I'm not anti these fights at all I again
I'm conflicted on it you're helping me
get to a different place which is good I
think what what's putting you there is
we don't need to even to use the word
argument because I don't really feel
like you're arguing no I'm not arguing
I'm literally I I think I'm having you
talk me into it more you know but I I
also think
you know if you look at the Jake Paul's
of the world and Logan Paul's if you've
if you look at the numbers that they've
brought into boxing like boxing you're
getting my point yeah boxing's getting
more popular more popular yeah and they
can literally go back and see okay well
when did Jake Paul and Logan Paul start
fighting well it's a this is a
correlation exactly to these guys
bringing a younger audience yeah so
there's that I really I really believe
that those guys doing this is huge for
MMA I really do I mean they didn't say
they were going to have a a boxing match
they said they were going to have an MMA
match and Zuckerberg is practicing
grappling what was the last person you
know big celebrity that focused on
grappling and not you know boxing it
it's been a we haven't really it's
unprecedented unprecedented that we've
seen
somebody at the people at this level
pushed MMA not boxing MMA not karate MMA
not sitting at a Pistons game MMA not
sitting at a football game MMA like it's
a big deal these guys we need those guys
talking about us in my opinion we need
them pushing us they are some of the
highest political figures in the world
and politics is leading the world right
now and it's not necessarily always
going in a
uh
uh as anybody would agree a perfect
Direction so I think letting the world
hash that out on a public forum with two
people who don't fight can't fight is
almost like
therapeutic yeah in the world yeah how
many people want to be in there doing
that and can and because these guys are
so rich and so have so much influence
they get the opportunity you know how
many veterans
uh in the military want to land on an
aircraft carrier and take off on
aircraft here they've been in the
military their whole life and they'll
never get that opportunity yeah but
because I'm with
certain groups of people outside of the
military I can do that I get that
opportunity is that does that mean that
every serviceman and every military man
means nothing or does it mean that I'm
coming and serving and supporting and
giving to the military yeah I mean
there's so many different Avenues we
could create this same
uh
conversation on and say that I'm the one
that's disturbing military right because
I'm not a military guy but realistically
it does nothing but serve it's all just
we're all working together we're all
connected yep and any differences we
have with people
we all want to Hash them out that's the
Common Ground we all have we all wanna I
think people don't fight about their
issues enough they sit on their issues
they stew about it I I don't agree to
disagree anymore I just disagree I want
to kill you and I hate you and it's like
why can't I disagree why can't I agree
to disagree and then if we need to fight
about it we can fight about it and then
it can be done and you know this you
know being fighting in the UFC and same
thing like and I think a lot of people
have never fought or surprised by this
like when you get done with that fight
win or loss however it went you hug each
other in the back you're like dude that
was great because you have this weird
like Bond and not too many people in the
world realize the sacrifices you made
just to get to the Octagon what all the
pressure you have to deal with so you
have this weird Bond like even guys who
didn't like me going into the fight
afterwards like what's up man you all
right and we're hugging and just like
there's this Bond so I guarantee you
obviously Elon Mark Zuckerberg you know
who knows where they lie as far as
politically but no matter what happens
after that fight I guarantee they
Embrace each other and they're probably
closer from it and who knows what maybe
now maybe they work together after this
maybe like that's crazy we did it and
then you start working together you're
getting my point it looks better for
everybody I really do believe that it
can create a really good thing and I
mean it really could these guys could
fighting you know like you just said you
hug in the back and think of the Avenue
of the average person who looks at the
pro fighter and says yeah that's how a
pro fighter handles it I could never do
that now you got two people who aren't
Pro Fighters and they're proving yes you
could and now we get to see and hear
from their perspective I haven't done an
eight-week camp or 12-week Camp I
haven't been training my entire life for
this I don't have the skills to do this
how do I feel and how do I look after
this fight oh I look like crap my head
hurts my nose is bleeding it's broken I
gotta go get a new nose job now like I
blew my knee out in the second round did
you tough it out out do you have that in
you even though you're not a pro fighter
who knows what we could see like does he
just fail break his Tone and say ah I
tap I'm done and then we find out why we
have Pro Fighters maybe that makes us
look better yep like there's so many
Avenues this could go I'm glad this has
happened yeah that's a fair point and
what's to wrap up on on this whole kind
of uh as people would say spectacle or a
gimmick fight which you know to each its
own people forget this could have
happened a long time ago not at the Elon
and Mark Zuckerberg level but Joe Rogan
and Wesley Snipes were down to fight and
like Dana was about to make it happen
this is back in the day dude
Dana almost fought Tito Ortiz in a
boxing match that's true Dana Tito Ortiz
but even before that this happened
before yeah even and it just was it was
unheard of so no one like really wanted
to jump the ship there but yeah Wesley
Snipes was down Rogan was completely
down I don't think Wesley realized how
down Rogan was Rose like 100 in and he's
like whoa take it easy man yeah he's
about to he's about to knock out blade
so we've seen how that goes he came out
late I would be too hyped I would be the
most hyped human being on earth oh I
probably
best friends but I love blade I've been
like he came out as Blaze oh so sick
with the glasses and that the
here cut out the back uh but on on the
real fights I mean this this this
weekend is a big one it's a good card
man it's a really good card that main
card is stacked and obviously you've
been just deep into it
um obviously has been a change as of
yesterday you got uh bo nickel uh got a
his opponent pulled out and they put in
that Val wood burn I think Woodburn in
the seven I'm kidding yeah I couldn't
find much on him man 7-0 he was supposed
to go in on the regional circuit and
then he was gonna do Dana White's
Contender series but they're like hey
forget they like Contender series here's
Bo nickel this is my take on a diamond
you know if I'm sure you've probably
looked into it more than I have but
at the level bow nickel is at
I it doesn't matter who they put in
there right now until he gets to the top
15 top 10 even top five I'm not too
concerned about anybody because I think
he's such an outlier he's one of the
biggest prospects that we've ever had
especially only being was he 4-05-0 to
see the level he's at and the way he's
able to mix things together like DC
would probably be the next closest
example but even DC it took a little
time the fluidity I see in BO Nick I'm
like man this dude is a is a super he's
a super Talent man not so you're always
breaking down film and stuff my question
for you would be what holes do you see
in BO nickel's game because all we do is
talk about how great he is I'm a big big
bow nickel fan I do things to be world
champion
but there there has to be some stuff
that you see with your you know expert
eye where you're like he needs to work
on this oh it could get diceyform at the
top
well yeah that I could give you that but
I think you have an extra eye too so why
don't you go first and tell us what you
see are his holes and then I'll I'll tee
on that yeah I think the biggest thing
would be as far as liability as far as
him when he does get to that upper
echelon would be his striking right now
he'll striking overall it's looked good
against lower competition I think he's
gonna and he does get a little wild so I
think you'd have to button that up get a
little more techno a little more
controlled I do like the way he's mixing
things up to say he's a blue belt's
hilarious you know you look at his
Transitions and his inverted triangle
um so I think he is going to have to
rely more heavily on his wrestling
because there's not there's not enough
hours in the day for him to get even
close to the level of uh Izzy's at on
the feet you know so I I think he is
going to have to really
focus on his MMA wrestling and looking
for those finishes
especially when he's once he gets the
upper echelon guys because because the
the Striking again there's not enough
hours in the day there's not enough
weeks for him to make up that Gap he's
gonna have to find what he does well
kind of like and I'm not saying a khabib
level where you know it could be just
Russian for the takedown but I think
he's gonna have to get comfortable
enough but know that that's his his way
to the belt is going to be through his
wrestling I hate when these top level
Grapplers and wrestlers fall in love
with striking and then they get to the
upper echelon and you know it's not
going to happen for him
yeah I think that Bo won't be that guy
he's too smart with the squad and the
team he has around him to not use his
wrestling and just fall in love with
striking like he's got a very good I
think a lot of it has to do with the
crew people you have around you my guy
Roman Bravo young has a super strong
crew around him and I notice it's a
similar crew as Bo nickel they keep very
solid leaders around like extremely
solid leadership is the biggest thing I
notice about that crew that makes him so
that makes all those guys so successful
they're not doing things on their own
they're not making all these decisions
on their own they're they're letting
they're handing these decisions over to
leaders that make decisions for them and
tell them what to do so they can torture
themselves and that's why they're so
good and he does that and
so with that crew one I see that being a
huge Advantage for him because he
listens to his leaders he's not making
his own Camp he's not running his own
show that's a huge huge thing for him
also they're not giving him fights and
this is how I came up in my career when
when they didn't have matchmakers really
and they didn't have managers and you
were just trying to book your own fights
and call the matchmakers yourself in my
day I always had a rule where I would
just the rule was as long as they don't
have three fights more at uh than me in
experience three fights I guarantee you
all beat their ass because
there's just like the experience is all
that I need to make sure I have it's not
even their tools it's the experience
that matters uh because of the athlete
that I am is how my mindset worked and
so
I know for him he's not getting booked
with guys through more than three fights
and then that means that this person
that he's fighting regardless of any
tool set that they have doesn't have any
more experience than him so it's hard to
beat somebody like an athlete like bow
nickel with the leadership and the
qualities that that he forces himself
into regularly it's hard to beat a guy
like that
when you when you don't have more
experience and more ideas on how to beat
somebody that's a better athlete at the
start right like if you if you had two
cars how much of a of a of a of a lead
would we give that other car exactly
that's a great question
and and they have the same amount of
races right so I kind of look at it that
way and then I think okay you're talking
about him getting into the top five the
top ten Bo nickel and uh that you said I
think that he could use some pickup on
the Striking and he I don't want him to
fall in love with the Striking too much
and get away from his grappling and
wrestling is what I heard so
I think that I go back to experience
because each of these fights that he has
he's going to learn those things so each
fight you have each Camp you have and I
know you can attest to this you learn
something different in that camp it's a
weird learning you get either a new move
or a new realization that I you know I
gotta get up from here or something and
I think that each fight that Bo nickel
has he's going to have a new progression
in this game where he realizes man I got
knocked out last week man I got
submitted last week I need to fix this I
need to fix that when you look at guys
like that you got to look at their
experience level and their results and
understand they're gonna adapt probably
faster than somebody with the same
amount of fights as them because of
their past history so if you just match
them up with somebody with the same
amount of fights he's pretty the chances
are usually in his favor you don't even
need to worry about the skill set
correct because
the tools offset each other with the
amount of wrestling he has so yeah he
doesn't have the right the Striking
why do so many wrestlers fall in love
with striking because so many guys stop
their takedowns because it's hard they
know it's coming so then they start all
right I gotta get my striking better
they start getting their striking better
they knock somebody out they forget to
go back to what opens up the wrestling
which is striking striking opens up the
wrestling it's not striking just to
strike it's striking to open up the
wrestling so I think that as Bo nickel
progresses these are the things that
they're just going to come natural to
him because the athlete he is the
leadership he has the people they're
going to bring in the experience the
level of fighter he's going to fight
they're not going to give him too much
too fast uh and I think that's what's
gonna happen with Bo nickel yeah I think
the UFC is doing a good job because back
in the day you know it was kind of like
hey man you know you can get eaten alive
if you can't hang what can we do you
don't belong here now they've done a lot
better job with guys like sugar shot
O'Malley with Patty pamlet
um you know and now with Bo nickel
they're kind of they're growing these
guys the right way they're the fan base
can get behind him and then also these
guys she made a great point is they're
getting the skill set in the in the
training camps even though it might not
be the toughest fight for him and they
might win in a minute it's the valuable
lessons and experience they're getting
that in those training camps which is
priceless so that yeah they're not
getting all the experience in the
Octagon because they're beating these
guys in a minute or two minutes but
those training camps is where they're
building those tools so when they do
have to you know use those assets
they're going to be there so that's the
biggest key there and kudos to the UFC
they've because I think they pushed
Darren till too fast you know they put
you in too fast you saw how that worked
out for them they push other guys too
fast uh Sage North cut you know it's
like damn man if they could have just
slowed down for that kid it's a marathon
not a Sprint if we just slowed down I
think he could have a better career
we're seeing one Championship things are
going better for him now but even with
me it was like I remember
you know you say a guy has three three
you won't find a guy with three or more
fights when coming up I had four fights
and then you know it's just the way it
worked and Ultimate Fighter and fighting
Roy Nelson who has 35 fights I have four
you know and I knew the experience was
gonna be an issue there and then shortly
after that I'm fighting a Gabriel
Gonzaga with 20 something fights and I
have seven at the time you know but that
experience is so valuable man it's
everything with these vets in there at a
high level so I think Beau Nico's gonna
be able to as you said his skill set
he's so athletic and the training camp
so he's gonna pick that up but I I'm so
high on Beau nickel man I I just think I
think he's the next great white hype man
there's not a lot of white guys doing it
out there and he's one of my faves he's
fun to watch He's fun to watch and you
know I love that this fight got pulled
from him on short notice and he's got to
adapt and cry and be sad and be scared
because welcome to MMA yeah everything
is not every I mean I can remember
showing up to fights and weighing in and
the guy just doesn't even shout to the
scale I'm ready and like like what are
we doing scale and I just go home and
get drunk like yeah I just went and did
a full camps to go get hammered with my
friends after party because we can rip
though at the afternoon I didn't show up
you know so welcome into Mabel Nicole
glad you're here with us yeah welcome
the highest level dude it's fighting and
then the the rest of the card now I was
I was talking about this card on Monday
especially in the main card a lot of it
is heavy favorites I think it's gonna be
a great card but if it goes according to
Vegas you're gonna get a landslide of
Victories uh it's like the Whitaker
duplicity's fight I get why the UFC's
doing espech in the middleweight
division Izzy needs fresh meat like we
we gotta find out that we need more
contenders for Izzy you know to sell
those pay-per-views because he's beat
everybody else
but the one guy you know if they want to
do policies to fight for that title shot
I think they gave him the worst matchup
possible in Robert Whittaker I just when
I look at the skill sets I look at their
previous fights you know Robert worker
doesn't lose to anybody not name Izzy he
said lots of fights since 2014 but to
Izzy adesanya so when I look at
duplicities I just don't see how he gets
it done am I off on that Dom do you do
you see a path for him
I think there's two ways to look at it
are we looking at it from the scope of
the fighters or the scope of the UFC
man that's a good question uh I would
say
I would say a little bit of both if
you're looking from a fighter standpoint
pick one we can't ride defense on this
one let's look at from the fighter
standpoint all right from the fighter
standpoint the way that duplicities gets
this done against Outlander that's the
question no against Robert Whittaker
against Robert Whitaker
um well there's ways to get it done can
he yeah I mean anybody yeah we we know
like I mean you're winning a fight until
you're not that's happened so many times
we can't even count you know
um all the way to peace cell pretending
to get hit and then yeah with an
overhand right like this is MMA right so
let's not sleep on that one with
Whitaker and duplicity anything happened
you can go with that anything can happen
but you know with that but now if we
went to the odds and like how this fight
could go I mean I see the left hook of
Whitaker being nasty the lead the lead
Hannah Whitaker is his best weapon the
thing about duplicity is he has a lot of
faints and a lot of fakes and he
wrestles enough closing the distance is
going to be the problem uh against
Whitaker because he's got such good
footwork and he does that back step real
nasty to hit you with the hook so if you
come forward hard he's got a back step
left hook if you stay where you're at
he's got a nasty lead right hand nasty
Elite right hand right kick he's got a
nasty left hook right kick and
everything kind of flows and merges
together to where if you try to get off
the center line on him he loops around
with kicks and if you stay on this
Center Line he hits you with the hook or
straight so you have to wrestle so how
do you get into the pocket unless you
have Jabs and unless you can beat the
jab and the lead hand of Robert
Whittaker the lead hand and the pressure
forward pressure duplicity has to have
forward pressure the whole time he has
to always beat the lead Hannah Whitaker
The Stance which is going to help him
beat up the lead leg of Whitaker on the
inside that will help take away a lot of
the the stuff that he leaps forward
because he's got a very wide stance
Whitaker and so these are the things he
can do to win I mean this is game plan
wise tactics structures if you had to
look at odds I mean yeah I agree
Whitaker is probably the favorite
um
minus 450. he's the favorite but I mean
I think he can he can get it done that's
the thing but now if we look at it
that's why this fight's happening you
also need to move you also need to give
Whitaker another shot you just have to
because of how well he's done in his
last he's finishing people and he's
looking good right he looks amazing so
he's yeah he's sick he's getting better
he's also improving he's not looking the
same so now you're like okay he's
improving he's knocking people out he's
winning he beats two plus C now we've
got somebody that can all right he's
gotten better look at these highlight
reels that he's had since that fight now
we're gonna make this rematch now look
at it bigger like who's who's fan base
can fill a stadium out more duplicity
and and uh style Bender or Whitaker
style then
um I mean depends where they do it right
like one's from South Africa I mean
Izzy's from Africa how many times have
we been to South Africa I mean zero okay
so who's gonna have this so if we're
looking at this from the USC standpoint
yeah yeah yeah I mean Whitaker is he is
the biggest live gate of all time
that's it so there we go so now we know
why I do play C Whitaker is happening
does it have anything to do with the
odds no absolutely not yeah
what does that have to do with I mean
that's it has to do with selling tickets
putting butts and seats 55 000 in a
stadium is what it has to do exactly
55 plus thousand and that's what we're
talking about so why are the odds so
crazy well 55 000 in the stadium sounds
pretty appealing to the UFC but also
it's a good fight and also you can you
can say Whitakers earned it and you can
you can say that he I want to see that
fight again anyways I think that
Whitaker made some adjustments I think
that he's got a smart team that and that
they can come up with a game plan to
make that fight closer and that fight
between him and stylebender that
knockout was one of the most incredible
Knockouts I've ever seen and I would
love to see you know Whitaker be able to
get a shot at that again because I think
he's incredible fighter and uh I just I
just like him so I I like it yeah he's
one of my favorites but also to
piggyback on that if do policies beats
Whitaker he deserves it man I think
that's also where the UFC's at too like
yeah man you beat Whitaker you're the
guy 100 you're getting a title shot well
that's the other thing so you got to win
win 400 under and he's from South Africa
now you have another guy from South
Africa from from that area right
that can that you can piggyback that
whole area of the world with yeah so
it's genius it is and it all works out
and it's a win-win-win-win-win-win
situation no matter who wins or loses
and if duplicity wins we get an
unbelievable win that nobody expected so
that's another win on top of a win yep
and the hype going into that would do
policies yeah I get it and now he's
built and now he's ready and now
everybody's on his train because he just
beat Whitaker so yeah that's the that it
makes sense to me me too across the
board and then the closest fight on the
card is brand Moreno versus pantosia I
think Pantoja is one of the most skilled
guys not to be a UFC champion he is such
a Savage to me I think people sleep on
him I do think
you know he's a guy people forget he
beat much he you know he's macheves one
loss I don't think a lot of people don't
remember that he's the guy that knocked
out Mark Chev
um you know so for for pantosia he's a
guy that has two wins over Brandon
Moreno
but I just when it when I when I look at
their skill set and I look at things
if you're a Bram Moreno fan which I am
he's one of my favorite Fighters where
this fight gets tricky for him is you'll
see bran will give up his back sometimes
if he gets taken down in the transitions
he'll give up his back and hand fight
and stand up very wrestler of him even
though he doesn't have a wrestling
background he'll hand fight and give up
his back with pantosia that is trouble
man at the level he's at with his
grappling you know when if he even sees
a a Slither to get your your neck he's
going to do it pantosia is a bad mama
jama now I do think Bram Rhino wins I
think it's by decision and people say
yeah but he's he's owing two against the
guy how's he going to get it done
if you look at when last time they
fought and obviously he lost a Pantoja
an ultimate fighter in the house but if
I look at their growth and who's gotten
better and also to spread Moreno's
mindset as a champion now and the awards
he had with figaredo it's just like I
just think Bram Reno has that Swagger
about him and he's gotten better since
they fought I think pantosia has always
been damn good and maybe he's gotten
five percent better but I think bran
Moreno you're talking Leaps and Bounds
better since last time they fought and
that'll be the difference we'll find out
but I do think Brian Moreno has gotten
better since they fought
yeah I think they have and what I like
is that the division is being talked
about I think that's most important you
gotta you gotta and that's what I gotta
give kudos to as as Brandon Moreno as
champion
I don't think people in the sport talk
enough about Champions and what a what
is a good Champion versus a champion
who's not doing their job that's my
question is there a standard for that
does anybody know what that looks like
or does it does anybody care when I look
at Brandon Moreno he's a true champion
and what I mean by that is he's fighting
um when he's healthy like if you're
healthy you fight and he is if you're
hurt you fix it and you come back but
even if you're hurt or if you're healthy
no matter what you're building the
division and what I mean by building the
division is you're talking about other
guys in the division you're you're
keeping your mouth open about other guys
in the division about whether you're
talking trash about them or talking them
up like that's the job is I'm at the top
and how do I build the rest of the
division and not just uh compete against
me and show why I'm the best but also
how do I build the rest of the division
to beat me how do I build the rest of
the division to be so much better than
me that the division
Rises because I've been involved yeah
it's a great Point yeah heavy license to
me what a champion is about and then
another level of that is
are you who are you making a difference
for uh as that champion who are like
look at Muhammad Ali the guy you know
just it wasn't just about him ever it
was about him and then he stood for what
he stood for for many it wasn't just
like I do this for me it was like and
that's why he's held
on a platform that's one of the best
Champions that ever lived was because he
wasn't just a selfish me me guy I mean I
think that's that I mean to correlate on
that I think it's too like when you talk
about the smaller weight classes you and
Uriah Faber did a lot of that man like
you guys are the witness of it I
appreciate that and and I do but I'm
really talking about Moreno on this one
because we've got a division and 125
pounds it's similar to 135 where we
needed you needed somebody to you needed
a rivalry you needed somebody to just
create it and make it
like I talked about remembrance thing
and right now
Moreno's creating those fights he's
creating that Legacy for the division
but also think about this Tom hate to
interrupt you but also think about this
not only is he doing it just for that
125 pound division he's also putting
Mexico on the map he has an entire
nation of Mexico on his back and now you
have these other with Alessa Grasso and
then you have yayir Rodriguez then so
they have three Mexican Champions which
is not to not so Indiana here's another
thing he's gotten given the entire world
as a champion coming from nothing and
what has he done with it has he you know
ran off and become a alcoholic and just
ruined his whole life has he continued
to fight continue to build the division
stand for his family be a man that's
being a human for the world or you just
trashing everything I'm the best living
on top of life going into movies touch
me none of you can touch me none of you
could be as good as me I am it I am the
most dangerous man in the world and
nobody like I've been ranked number two
in the pound for poundless before and
the only person I was behind is
Demetrius Johnson that I had beaten yeah
so
should I run should I have been running
around you know saying that I'm hungry
the greatest gift from heaven and stop
making a difference for my family and
the people around me or just care about
myself and what I can get or just say
you know what I'm leaving the division
you guys could never be as good as me
yeah why are we doing that why are we
killing a division do you really need it
that bad do you really need to be the
best so bad that you'd kill everybody
behind you just to say I'm the best in
the rest of the division in the UFC will
never exist again except for you is that
what this being a champion is about now
when when you give that example Don
would you say you're alluding to like a
Conor McGregor Tendencies you know like
I don't have any one person you got
how many years of Champions do you have
done both sides of this story and my
question is as a champion what is
important to you to choose which which
version and why
yeah I think what brand Moreno is doing
and I don't know if you spent time with
Brandon he has to be one of the nicest
people on the freaking planet man this
dude is just such a good person
like kids you want your would you want
your kids following him 100 my kids look
up to them they're half Mexican for
God's sakes you're making a difference
for a bigger a bigger thing with you
with who you're being not what you're
doing yeah and I respect that about
Brandon Moreno it's his way of being is
being carried as a true professional as
a true champion as a true human being
for the people and coming from Mexico
that makes me you know him coming from
Mexico and me being a Mexican descent
and half white half Mexican on my dad's
side and my mom's white in English and
Irish and having that mixture like it
makes me proud to see a Mexican Champion
just be so wholesome and so real and so
for the people and such a good you know
keeping this stuff together now is he as
famous as a Mike Tyson no no and then
you go well why well Mike Tyson I mean
that's like anybody who lights a house
on fire everybody's gonna go run and
watch it yep you know that works when
Mike Tyson was at his Peak it was a
burning house he admits that it was just
have it you know and so he got so much
to him and so much attention and one of
my favorite quotes of Mike Tyson was God
will teach you a lesson by giving you
everything you ever wanted yeah that's
uh that's one of my favorite quotes by
Tyson he's so smart from from having him
live that life now look at the type of
champion he's transitioned to as an
older man agree have you ever have you
done a show Dom have you ever done hot
boxing I have I have not I've watched it
oh we gotta make that happen I know I
know steam well you and him together I
like seeing his brain I like seeing
where he was because I can relate and I
like seeing where he's at because he's
giving now he's doing nothing but giving
you and him like two of the greatest
Minds in the fight game of all time you
have got to get together man that would
be oh I would I would love to listen
he's such a wise guy because of his
street smarts and what he's been through
in his career and that's kind of another
way of what I'm alluding to Brandon is
like look at who he's shifted into yeah
like if this was the person at the top
could he have been at the top I wonder I
wonder what he would say could this
person he's being could he be both could
he be this person he is today and could
he still be that killer and can humans
access both sides like that is that
possible that so I I and looking at him
especially the way he was in that how
ferocious and mean he was and he looked
at some of his press conferences like
I'm gonna eat your children like Jesus
Christ man he had to do whatever be that
in the fight and then he leaves and
comes in a podcast and go look I know I
said that the other day guys but you
know that was just my fighting self the
real self is who you're looking at now
yeah I don't know imagine like I know
how powerful of a human being that would
be the differences he's making now
because he's he's not just about you
know eating people's children yeah
making a difference he's not talking
crazy as create you know he's he's
giving so I respect Brandon Moreno and
the hunter what he's doing for the 125
pound division because he's he's laying
a beautiful Legacy of you know you can
respect the legacies creating and the
type of human he's being do you think
you get the done Dom you think he gets
it done this weekend I mean you probably
can't pick because you got to work the
fights uh yeah well no I I I'm actually
uh on ESPN so I'm doing uh pre and post
fight show oh so you're gonna have to
pick on there right
gonna have to pick yeah
um I like Merino on that one I think his
left I think I think his lead hand can
get it done his his best weapon is his
lead hand I know that sounds weird but
when I sparred him I've worked with him
oh really yeah I've gotten I've gotten a
train with him and it's It's Tricky it
his left hand he holds it down and he
waves it down at his waist like this
yeah and it's like it can come up it can
come around it can come over or it can
come straight there's four different
directions and then he's he's quick man
and he's tricky so like it's deceptive
and his lot his arms are longer than you
then you like it's like one of those
Inspector Gadget arms kind of like Rob
font yeah like you're in there and you
don't realize until you're getting your
face jabbed off that well he's got that
little extra inch that you're not used
to feeling that adjustment like usually
I'm out of the way that's that's
touching me now but he's talking to me
yeah so it's weird he's got a weird and
then he's good with his lead leg too so
and then the the
the thing that that makes it tough is
the grappling pantosia's grappling I do
believe is is better like just more
fundamentally sound is what I mean more
fundamentally sound and I also think
pantosia in the chaos he excels in the
chaos if that makes sense like when the
when the house is on fire pantosia does
very very well in that where he's
looking for opportunities to get your
neck get a leg get an ankle I think when
when the chaos is happening he just has
a slight Edge over Moreno in that chaos
yeah I'm hearing like you like pentos's
decision-making skills a little bit more
yeah yeah in that chaos in that hectic
kind of uh fight Booth but
when you watch figureheado versus Moreno
you see that in that place he thrived as
well so that's why this fight is no fun
I can't wait I can't wait Mexican
Fighters want that we're good in that
yeah hell yeah you guys are historically
just are yep it's just what you guys do
man and then the main in the main event
yeah Rodriguez versus
um Alex volkanovsky tell me if I'm off
on this Dom
when I watched the volkanovski maksha
fight after that fight I had so much
respect for Alex I'm like oh I can't
believe he he went toe-to-toe with that
guy that's insane
and then after I went there's not a
145er on this planet who can beat Alex
volkanovsky after watching I'm like
there's no way if he was able to do that
to mock Chev win some rounds some people
thought he won the fight that's Up For
Debate but just the way he performed
against a bigger guy in mock Jeff who's
so goddamn dominant I thought 145
screwed and that's not a knock on Yaya
it's not knocking all these other guys I
just don't see anybody beating
volkanovsky after watching Holloway
fights what would the the body of work
that he's put in I think he's the best
to ever do it at 45.
I will say uh yeah you can't really how
can you argue that at this point with
what he's done he's his his record and
the people that he's beaten shows that
um but if I look at you know habits make
Styles and styles make fights and I
always say that and what are the habits
of Rodriguez versus the habits of
okanovski well the habits of okinaw is
here to stay standing and switch stance
and stay on the outside and play that
game and stuff takedowns
is
get on the inside Force takedowns and
keep you there yep so what we know about
those habits is how do those habits line
up we know if Market Chef can't get him
there and keep him there is he's not
comfortable and we know volkanowski can
stop from being there and stay on the
outside he'll do well he was able to do
that more the question is how does the
how do those habits line up with the
Rodriguez who doesn't care to take you
yeah man doesn't care to wrestle you and
only once what vulcanovski chooses
which is free-flowing outside movement
switching stance and he's the shorter
fighter
and if you watch Rodriguez versus Emmett
Emmett is the perfect build and body
type to prepare for the next fight
against vulcanos correct same height
same stature same strength same
durability same neck same no neck all
that stuff right so now you look at
volcanocyan Emmett's skills and habits
well
Emmett's not quite not even quite as
fundamentally sharp with his striking as
volcanovski so volkanoski has the edge
in that against uh
in the Striking so now that's why this
fight's happening because you got a guy
that can he stand with the Rodriguez
because he will can he stand with them
or will he do what everybody's done to
Rodriguez which is will he become the
market chef
and put him on the fence and grind him
into the floor because that's what
everybody's done when they beat
Rodriguez they get tired of getting
kicked and hit and they finally pressure
them they put him on the fence and they
melt them down into the corner and while
he's going for arm bars on the Platos
and triangles they're keeping his head
down in the cubby and they're just
stalling out the rounds while they're
punching him I mean I could see
vulcanovsky look at what he did to
Ortega in that position I think he
punched in the guard straight for like a
minute and a half two minutes after
getting out of two submission attempts
and had no no air or blood to his head
correct so does he is he cool with being
on top of you in the guard more than
cool he's actually thriving and
comfortable there so my question is
can Rodriguez stop
volkanoski from taking him down can he
stop okanovski from pushing him back can
he stop volkanoski from being keeping
him on her fence because that's what
makachev did to volkanosky and that's
how volcanovski beat Market basically I
see it as Rodriguez needs to follow what
volcanovski did with makachev yep
and he and Rodriguez needs to fight that
style and then let his hands go once he
stuffs all the grappling attempts of
volcomovski if he can stop every
grappling attempt every time volcanazi
tries to grab him every time he tries to
put him on the fence he can untie and
get back to the center every time he
takes him down he can escape enough of
those you're going to be forced to stand
with Rodriguez for a long fight and
those little things can get in the body
kicks the speed
uh he's so fast in those first two
rounds and I think he's the fastest in
the whole division in those first two
rounds I think the most dangerous too as
far as putting your lights out with
speed yeah that that's the X Factor
there if if he can't stop that though
kind of the grappling Onslaught
it just the more time that that Alex is
spending in the middle of that Octon the
more chances he has of getting knocked
out exactly and if volcanovski gets him
down early
it's the opposite exactly it goes the
other way yep you take away his early
speed you take away his early finish
power energy and now in the third fourth
fifth round you have a much easier to
deal with Rodriguez if you look in the
in the results this isn't a fact this is
if you look at past habits past results
that's what you'd be looking at on the
film yeah it doesn't mean that's the
Rodriguez we're gonna see though
true yeah it's a fascinating fight
fascinating fight could be a rough one
for Mexico if yair and Brandon Moreno
were to lose it could happen but
I don't know if you can make a rough
night from Mexico true unless Canelo
were to lose in some weird fashion yeah
so if you can stop Mexico there's no
such thing as a rough man dude you're
just in Mexico bro yeah yeah it's still
Mexico Coronas man you're good
um I'll get you out of here soon brother
you had a you had a fan drive you home
or drive you to the airport in
Jacksonville
I thought that was super cool man what
the hell the hell that come about well
you know so I was in Jacksonville and I
get there and niner one of The Producers
one of the guys that works the desk for
me in like trafficks us and all that
stuff when I'm doing color
he goes hey man I got just booked my
flight and I'm like how'd you book your
flight what do you mean you booked your
flight he's like yeah I'm out of here
right after the show there's a sick
there's a seven o'clock I'm like what so
boom I jump on the phone I get on it but
before the show even starts I book my
flight to leave directly after the show
tight move so
finish TV Sprint I gotta run I gotta get
to my car get to the hotel so I Sprint
to the car with attic he drives me in
his minivan with his kids car seats we
dropped me off at the hotel is hilarious
drops me off the hotel in his suit later
man
run up pack my stuff throw it into the
car get to the airport
make it and the only reason I can get to
the car and make it is because of this
fan so I'm running out and I'm like
trying to get this Uber and I'm like
it's gonna take eight minutes I'm
like behind I'm like cutting it as close
as possible to make this flight I mean
we had a hard six out on TV and my
flight boards at seven so I had to leave
in my suit get all the way I saw the
pack my bag everything get to the hotel
pack my bag then get to the airport
if this fan didn't save me that 10
minutes by being like hey you know can I
get a picture real quick I gotta go
though I'm gonna hurry on I'm trying to
get this Uber he's like I'll give you a
ride I'm like really it's like yeah no
problem I'll take you right to the
airport we're only 10 minutes away I got
you and I was like yes all right let's
go you're my Uber what do you need from
me and I assigned all the stuff he
needed gave him a video whatever he
needed and he ended up being a veteran
oh sick now was that 10 minute drive you
breaking down UFC 290 though you know
what I'm saying it's like you're gonna
you're gonna pay one way or the other
man you know
that's great dude how uh I'll get you
out on this how how you feel about Henry
cejudo uh dipping out of the the fight
with with Al Joe I'm I'm sorry with
Cheeto
um I want to ask you what you think
first I think I heard Rumblings early on
I know his team where he never he never
signed the contract he never said yes
let's do this and you know the UFC is
going to UFC and they're like no this is
the fight that's what we're doing
cheetah wants to do it and he's down and
they announced it and said I was like my
shoulder's not great man similar to the
AL Joe uh sugar fight aljo's like they
announced it I I really like some time
off and heal like no this is what's
happening so aljo's like all right let's
do it you know hopefully I can figure
this out I think sojudo's injury was so
bad he was like there's no way there's
just no way so I think it's a little bit
on both sides to blame there you know I
think the UFC announced it too fast
um who knows who how bad Henry sudo's
fight was he says his shoulder's really
bad he says it's a 50 Frontier if you
were to go through Camp things you'd
tear it fully and then you'd probably
have to retire so I get both sides I get
both sides
I talked to Cheeto uh on Sunday about it
you know he's like happens sucks
he's like live and learn hopefully they
find somebody else he wants Peter yawn
yeah I would say everything what made
sense about that except that Henry said
yeah but I'd like Peter yawn or
so-and-so after like you had that whole
statement about this and that and but
then you give us two opponents that are
ranked higher than Vera which tells me
that you didn't want somebody right
Rivera was at yeah
like that's that's the that's where he
tells his truth is the thing it's like
my shoulder hurts too much for Vera but
if we can get algeman Sterling or oh
Peter yarn my shoulder doesn't hurt as
bad we can make this work I can I can
make this work so now this is when I was
trying to make like
one of the questions I got is hey Dom
you're on the undercard on the on you're
on like The Fight Pass prelims under
card like fighting Casey Kenny at the
Apex like you're a former world champion
why would they do that to you well it's
not about them doing it to me it's about
me choosing that slot because it's the
most scene slot on the card because it's
right before the main card and I wanted
to get put in front of the most eyes it
was about facing somebody that was a
southpaw to prepare for the rest of the
division to be a world champion about
getting somebody from Tucson the shot
against a former champion and see what
he can do as well because he's from my
hometown and it was about taking a
chance and seeing if I'm a real fighter
or not it's not just about getting title
shot it's about seeing what I can learn
from these experiences from being way
behind from being way injured and some
nobody said I could do this again again
for the third time and here I am again
facing this guy how much risk and how
much pressure is it for me to lose
versus Casey Kenny on that fight yep
I had to bite that I had to put my ego
aside to be on that position I had to
you know you have to be able to do these
things if you want to be the best you're
down to do the work you're down to do
the work you got to build a division
that's building the division giving the
Casey Kenny's a shot is building the
division uh giving the guys you know me
facing Vera was giving building the
division the way I look at it is I'm
gonna face her an hour I'm gonna face
him later so I might as well just fight
him now on this Main Event get ready for
the next title shot after each fight is
a preparation for the next fight unless
you're just trying to scapegoat stuff
and get what's best for you and the way
I see Henry is he some fights are worth
it for his children some aren't so how
do you decide that who's how do you
decide who's good enough for you and who
isn't well it's up to the UFC to make
those choices so I got the same fight
offer he did
and I took a Casey County fight earlier
than that and then I took a Pedro Munoz
fight earlier than that both on under
cards by the way not on a main card that
they're trying to put him on then I take
the fight with Vera
so I'm not saying to spread I'm saying
that look we can't even get this guy to
take one yeah
he's been out this whole time he gets a
title shot and now then after that after
the title shot they didn't drop him to
the bottom of the line they're going to
give him a ranked opponent in the top
five big name I had to think that it
wasn't even raised yeah on the undercard
as a two-time world champion on the
prelims yep so let's not forget what the
matchmakers do to certain guys and not
to others and it's okay but also I chose
it
I chose that route I chose to say yes is
what I'm trying to tell you I chose to
see us I chose to say yes to Pedro Munoz
I chose to say yes to Vera because I
wanted to build back up from the bottom
of the ladder to the top and show it can
be done even after I've done it twice
already yep I was clever I didn't make
it all the way there that last fight
close though got a stinger in that fight
and got hurt but the bottom line is I'm
still there I'm still in the top ten so
who would I have to who would I have to
fight next these are the questions so
we'll talk about Henry I'm just like I'm
cool I get being hurt I have a hurt
shoulder now I'm in the same boat we
both have a reconstructed shoulder our
right shoulders constructed we both have
surgery I thought Henry
in the pandemic where all the borders
were closed right three months after my
shoulder surgery or the world title he
had a full camp
for Jose Aldo I took that fight and it
was great but the bottom line is now
it's like then he retires sits out three
years like build a division give some
fights to these other guys that's what
this position is about about being
championed that and now I'm gonna leave
yep and I'm gonna give all the
responsibility to whoever's second best
and now the division's dead because he
like stay in there build it keep
grinding put your put your put your
legacy on the line if you're really as
good as you think you are go fight Vera
go fight Casey Kenny go fight Pedro
Munoz before you get that top three slot
go build the division Be A Champion yeah
it's a great Point have they given you
any Rumblings when you're going to be
back in lockdown like I just said
I can also get Henry because my
shoulders also hurt I shot it with some
stem cells yeah I'm in the I retor it
after the verified so I have to verify
I'm training
boom share my retirement infraspinatus
which is a rotator cup Tenon in the back
of the shoulder which is before I had
reconstructed my bicep tendon and my
supraspinatus so those are two of the
three now I pour the one in the back
partial so there's a partial care it's
not all the way it's like shooting stem
cells you hope that it heals it up you
do the rehab I'm in the rehab phase now
and then I start training and when I
start training if the shoulder works or
it doesn't that's when I'll know and
that's when you say hey let's start
looking for something here yeah take
your time that's why when they go God
what are you doing you're like man
I'm rehabbing my shoulder when it gets
strong I'm going to try it I'm going to
go into Camp I'm gonna give it
everything I got but then you know
that's why you have leaders your leaders
are going to say Dom we can't have you
three days on three days off because
your shoulder's shutting down you gotta
just have you seven days on if you can't
do that we're not gonna I'm not gonna
Eric will say I'm not gonna we're not
booking this like you gotta be yeah you
got to be 100 healthy I'm not so these
are all things that I'm sure Henry's
going through as well and then he's got
to chalk it out like do I want to go in
there with this partially hurt shoulder
to fight a champion or do I want to go
in there with this partially hurt
shoulder to fight a Casey Kenny or Pedro
Munoz in the top ten he's saying well
for a title fight it's worth it but all
you other guys it's not no you don't
that's not how this works how it works
yeah I get it because I'm gonna have to
fight somebody in the top ten and my
shoulders in the same status and I'm not
over here whining about it it's just
what it's going to be I get it brother
that's why I want your Insight on it
well you're the best man I appreciate
you doing it brother you're one of my
favorites to talk to your absolute best
man go crush it this week and uh we'll
be hitting you up harass you and come
back on man you're the best thanks for
the talk buddy appreciate it brother
good to see you man later later dog